I feel like when the rain hits the
ground people accelerate more Geraldo
Arias decided to take its Sunday as he
noticed the roads were a bit hectic
Sunday brought a good amount of rain to
the valley and with it major accidents
could be seen all around take a look as
the RTC of southern Nevada had a threat
of post alerts to their Twitter page of
all the accidents that occurred
throughout the day the biggest one
happening near the 215 and Valley View
Nevada Highway Patrol confirming that
they all suffered non-life-threatening
injuries at one point all four lanes
were blocked but all Lanes heading east
and Westbound have since reopened locals
who were out and about today sharing
what they saw out on the roadways and
how it was for them driving in the rain
they were a little bit slick so I just
slowed down and took my time I think
people just kind of lose their senses
and are we don't have it a lot so people
don't have a lot of experience in it
everybody's not aware of the rain and
the weather you know so they're just
driving like regular and they need to
slow down they just need to pay
attention
as for the 14 car pile up on the 215
everything was cleared up by 6 30 this
evening reporting live Madison Kimbrough
8 News Now